a lawyer for the main suspect in the
death of the teenager harry dunn
have said that she is willing to perform
community service in the united states
in an interview on a podcast they also
say that ann sucules
is willing to make what they call a
contribution
in his memory well let's see uh what
several people think about this uh we're
joined now by
harry's mother uh charlotte charles and
rad seeger uh the family spokesman
um guys great to see you both again um
what do you make of all of this i
suspect i know the answer to this
question already
but it's an offer of community service
and some form of
payment of reparation enough for you
guys
she needs to come back to the uk and go
through the uk justice system
you know it's not up to us then it's not
up to them to decide
what penalty if anything should be
handed down you know
she wants to find a resolution the only
resolution
is to face the uk justice system you
know
we all know diplomatic community is not
there to cover
her and these circumstances know it's
theirs to protect people in hostile
countries
we're not one of those we're an ally we
need to move on
she needs to move on with her life we
need to rebuild ours but without her
going through the uk justice system that
can't be done
it it was the the two words community
service that kind of
stuck in my mind when i first heard
about this development in in your story
charlotte
the idea that going and picking up
litter from the side of the freeway
uh would in some way compensate or or
gratify you
for the loss of your son
and i'll deal with that if if you don't
mind good morning
you know i think in this country we
placed
you know extraordinary value on human
life um particularly when it comes to a
child
and when harry was killed in these
circumstances
aunt sakuyas was charged with causing
death by dangerous driving
it is not for any of us on the airwaves
to determine
what should be the outcome in this case
that is the matter for
a judge ultimately if she's convicted of
any crime and
we don't have a system in this country
where we get to pick and choose from a
menu
of um sentences
i mean you know if that's if that's
we're really heading down that road now
it's a road to ruin because you and i
would want to do the same and so would
everybody else and we would all be out
there doing
community service the simple fact is mrs
jeffress needs to engage with the crown
prosecution service and
the family's position has always been
that
um ban securities needs to get to the
starting block to face the uk justice
system
what happens to her after that is not a
matter for the family as
victims of a crime and it's up to
it's up to other people but for you know
he was
as the whole nation knows harry was a
wonderful boy
and his life did matter and we do not
get to kill people in this country
now and simply walk away um
sean another snippet that fell from the
from the lips of the lawyer
uh was that ms sikulis is apparently
willing to meet with
you with you with the family i'm just
quoting here to provide whatever
information they're seeking
we truly hope that we can do that and
give the mama the family some
some measure of peace i mean are you
open to that
i've never said never um we are very
open to that
um i can only speak on behalf of myself
but i am very open to that
but that has to be with the correct
people in the room you know the
mediators
the therapists and only after
she has gone through the uk justice
system
um not before certainly not before
um can you bring us up to get i
understand of course there was the the
civil claim that you were looking at in
the united states
where are we with that this morning
well look that's a very important strand
and in the family's pursuit for justice
and you know we we we get criminal
justice and we get civil justice
and the parents are taking giant strides
in that in that
direction and over the course of the
coming weeks notwithstanding
mrs accuses attempt to strike out that
claim unbelievably
um which which has been allowed to
proceed um
both mr ciphulis and her husband are now
um looking at having to give disclosure
of all their documents as well as
face uh what they call the united states
depositions where they
have to come into our lawyer's office
and give testimony under oath
about what happened that night so look
you know this this
the pendulum is now swinging very firmly
in this family's favor this
holy innocent family after 18 months of
barbaric torture and we will pursue
um you know their legal rights to the
fullest extent possible over there
as well as ensuring that the cps do
their job over here
does that mean then that that you you
both have confidence
that justice for harry will will
ultimately be done
i think as i've said to you now and i've
said to many other people
we would not have started this campaign
if we didn't know where it was going to
end up but we we remain just as
confident today as we did when we
started the campaign and i can share
with your viewers that
there are an awful lot of very high
level discussions going on between
london and washington and we we remain
very very confident
well that is that is indeed good to hear
uh rad charlotte good to see both of you
again thanks very much for joining us in
the program this morning
thanks thanks for having us